[Aplausos]
[Música]
é tudo isso aí mais um pouco a gente vai
falar eu eu gosto muito de videogames é
o passa boa parte do meu tempo jogando e
eu tenho certeza que se não você está
aqui e ouvindo com certeza um primo mas
sobre é um tio bom a gente está sendo
gravado e por quem sabe o seu amor por
seu bisavô já gostava eu gosto bastante
a a minha esposa sempre me apoiou
bastante nessa parte
mas no começo ela não entendia muito bem
o negócio videogame eu vi ela comentando
com os amigos é ele fica lá no quarto
dele um fone de ouvido conversando
sozinhos mas será que eu sou de
respeitar
eu gosto bastante mas jogar videogame
meio solitário né e pegar o solário num
encontro de família ou então no meio do
bar para ver o whatsapp para ver o
twitter
o instagram não é solitária também mais
do que isso é perda de tempo
a gente aqui falando de acidente com o
objetivo que a gente pode fazer com o
tempo livre
espero que a gente não pode utilizar os
videogames e utilizar melhor a internet
pra modificar um pouco da sociedade o
nosso redor
existe um tempo se chama os clientes
time corintiano é basicamente quanto
tempo você fica frente a uma tela
inicialmente de tv eles queriam saber
quanto tempo a exposição ao uso da tv
podia ser prejudicial e depois na
verdade foi colocado para duas outras
telas para celulares é para computador
porque quando você está à frente a uma
tela você não está exposto solos você
está exposta tudo que está trazendo
informação pra você e quando a gente
fica exposto a esse tipo de informação
tem coisas boas vêm coisas com isso a
internet está em todo o lado e eu
costumo falar que a internet está cada
vez mais social a socialização da
internet porque cada vez mais as pessoas
têm facilidade de acesso a ela
mas ao mesmo tempo cada vez mais a
internet tem acesso às pessoas e com
isso com essa dominância das redes
sociais sobre a nossa realidade
a gente fica exposto as partes ruins as
partes tóxicas na internet é aquele
vídeo que você recebe preferia nem ter
recebido ou aquela corrente que só quer
gerar medo nas pessoas
ou então um comentário sobre algum tipo
de evento recente que acaba gerando
discussão
tanta coisa desnecessária tanto ódio e é
difícil de observar que se você tem um
jogo pela internet e quando se fala em
competição os nervos ficam à flor da
pele
é claro que ele também vai ter discussão
em especial quando a gente fala em jogos
competitivos e jogos competitivos
multiplayer de mais um jogador
quando eu falo nisso eu tô falando
principalmente nos esportes
se você não conhece ainda essa essa
palavra esportes é é branco e sei se
acostumando com ela bem rápido
a gente está falando de um mercado que
girou em 2017 cerca de 500 milhões de
dólares no mundo todo existe uma
previsão para em 2020 girar cerca de 1,4
bilhões
mas nem só a venda do jogo ou os
campeonatos e as pregações
a gente está falando de produções
musicais colecionáveis como brinquedos
peças de roupa enquanto os jogadores
a gente está falando mesmo de estrelas
como a gente fala na internet né
os jogadores mostrando os profissionais
mostrando eles jogando online ao vivo e
as pessoas interagindo com eles por um
certo valor
então quando a gente fala nesses
esportes
nessa catimba que tem entre os jogadores
a gente acaba vendo que lembra um
pouquinho às vezes nosso futebol também
né
às vezes aquela tiradinha com o outro
time acaba em um pouquinho adiante e
acaba chegando a violência violência
entre os próprios jogadores violência
entre os atletas e os torcedores e às
vezes está vazando completamente do jogo
em 2017 a gente teve um caso de um
jogador coreano muito famoso a cor é
inclusive uma grande potência nos
esportes e estava transmitindo uma
partida online na sua webcam e no meio
do jogo começou a ficar irritado
namorada dele foi conversar com ele e
ele acabou agredido fisicamente então
uma agressão física transmitida ao vivo
pela internet para milhares de jovens e
foi afastado do cenário competitivo e
uma investigação policial foi instaurado
então puxa se isso consegue mexer tanto
com as pessoas e gera tanta violência
assim como a gente vai se proteger disso
porque a grande maioria dos jovens e das
crianças que estão jogando esses jogos
não estão preparados para enfrentar
coisas pesadas assim só que eles têm a
ele estão assistindo esses atletas que
vão para os estados unidos moram lá eles
estão numa game house uma casa na qual
eles treinam com outros times participam
de campeonatos ao redor do mundo vão
mudando de vida assim como por exemplo
acontece com os jogadores de futebol ou
com músico é muito comum que esses
jovens também queriam isso para a vida
deles e eu comecei a pensar poxa tem
tanto o projeto social legal hoje a
gente por exemplo vai conhecer um
projeto muito legal de música que
utiliza a música utiliza o os esportes
pra prazer essa criança é uma
possibilidade de função mas socializar
ela mas então como é que a gente podia
fazer isso com jogos e aí eu chego num
porque eu tô aqui em 2002 eu comecei a
jogar um desses jogos competitivos que
eu não vou explicar um jogo
completamente mas só para vocês terem
uma idéia são cinco jogadores contra
cinco jogadores e cada um deles se
encontra naquele momento não se conhece
previamente
então é um jogo que é multiplayer né a
gente joga com pessoas como nossos
aliados
só que eu não conheço a esso só que é
muito importante a cooperação entre eles
para vencer
beleza comecei a jogar como qualquer
outro jogo
e em 2014 era o jogo que eu mas jogava
assim eu queria melhorar no jogo deve
tornar profissional já tinha meu emprego
também satisfeito o emprego
hoje eu queria ser melhor então eu
comecei a fazer algumas vídeo aulas além
de alguns artigos e mesmo assistir
alguns cursos sobre o jogo mas assim
vídeo-aula artigo sobre o jogo é na
verdade é exatamente isso toda a
comunidade cria conteúdo para os jogos e
isso a gente tem análise de quais são as
tendências dos campeonatos mundiais
quais são os personagens que estão mais
fortes
os itens que melhor equipe com esses
personagens uma melhor estratégia é mais
ou menos se alguém é das antigas elevada
que as revistas que a gente comprava que
tinha as dicas de jogos mas pra mim não
era o suficiente e ainda não ia bem não
como eu queria
então encontrei um artigo e alguns
poucos poucas pessoas publicavam artigos
sobre comportamento do jogador o que o
jogador pensa enquanto joga agora tem
uma palavra bonita é mais de sexo mais
de 7 do campeão
e pra mim acabou sendo revelador porque
falava muitas vezes sobre como você tem
que analisar muito bem as duas derrotas
para saber aonde que você errou como
você tem que valorizar o seu adversário
e ver qual foi o ponto forte dele pra
que então você consiga corrigir analisar
melhor as minhas vitórias também quais
são os meus pontos fortes como enfrentar
os meus medos antes de entrar contra um
outro jogador que vai ser completamente
randômico nas suas ações ou mesmo a
ansiedade antes de uma partida que pode
ser decisiva
achei legal comecei a aplicar isso e de
fato melhorou no jogo
quando eu aprendi a lidar melhor com as
pessoas que estavam junto comigo contra
mim não foi bem melhor
cara eu achei isso muito legal e não
tinha nada disse em português ou pelo
menos muito pouco então eu pensei ah é
na época viajava muito pré pra fazer os
plantões ainda viagem e eu queria e
ouvindo isso no plantão para otimizar
meu tempo
então pensei vou fazer um teste sobre
isso eu creio opine qual cast que é um
podcast que inicialmente era publicado
sob forma de áudio e depois passou a ser
vídeo no youtube e comecei a publicar
sem gratuitamente para ver se alguém
mais interesse
aos poucos eu comecei a receber feedback
de pessoas que estavam de fato
melhorando a auto vamos pensar no jogo
atuando melhor com os aliados
depois de um ano de projeto já acumulava
cerca de 160 mil visualizações alguma
coisa tava fazendo de certo mas melhor
do que isso eu comecei a receber alguns
feedbacks que eu não esperava
eu comecei a receber feedbacks de
pessoas me contando que olha só eu
aprendi a lidar melhor com com os meus
aliados no low e eu tenho percebido que
eu tô mais tolerante com os meus colegas
no trabalho
ah eu depois que eu aprendi o jeito que
ele falou que a gente tem que se
organizar para poder para poder fazer os
treinos e também para poder render mais
no jogo
eu tenho melhor na faculdade eu tô
sabendo estudar melhor ou seja por mudar
o comportamento dentro do jogo a pessoa
estava começando a mudar o comportamento
nas relações físicas do dia a dia isso
com uma ação pequena como eu fiz
então será que a gente não pode utilizar
os jogos ea internet da mesma maneira
que esses projetos sociais porque não é
legal como alguém que está fazendo
música e aprendi que ele tem que ser
harmônico com os outros colegas dele
para poder fazer uma música legal ou
então aquela clássica é um jovem
violento tem dificuldade de socialização
entre uma arte marcial e aprendi a
respeitar o seu adversário e com isso é
mais tolerante ou mesmo respirar fundo e
chuta aquele pênalti decisivo
o que eu quero dizer pra vocês é que eu
gostaria que vocês vissem esses jogos
competitivos não só como lazer
mas como oportunidade de chegar em
pessoas que de outra maneira seria muito
difícil chegar porque geralmente quem
joga esse tipo de jogo é que fica assim
como eu fechado no quarto dele jogando
têm mais dificuldade de socializar
fisicamente
são pessoas tímidas são pessoas que têm
mais dificuldade para se expressar ea
internet é um meio de comunicação e
expressão o ângulo
essas pessoas podem se encontrar dividir
experiências e realizar coisas
gigantescas no rio de janeiro no ano
passado eu pude ajudar um grupo que se
organizou e vai jogar online acaba na
partida juntos e joão
vamos conhecer a beleza e começar a
pensar em filhos acabaram se organizando
para fazer um encontro de todos eles e
eles aproveitaram para fazer uma doação
em massa de sangue mais ou menos 30
pessoas foram doar sangue por uma
comunidade que não existiria de outra
maneira senão através dos jogos online o
nosso escrete time só cresce a gente
cada vez mais fica preso a mattel
no entanto a necessidade de socialização
do ser humano é a mesma desde a
pré-história o animal ser humano ele
necessita de socialização ele necessita
de conexão
então a gente pode utilizar esses jogos
a gente pode utilizar a internet de uma
maneira diferente porque internet gente
não é só a no facebook ele recebia uma
pessoa putz pessoa me adicionou ele vai
ter que adicionar para ficar chato a
votar
aquela foto lá que eu que eu tirei na
minha última viagem no metrô bater sei o
que eu vou começar a discutir com as
pessoas no twitter ao falar aqui que o
político não sei o que vou trocar
e também não é só aquele bom dia da avó
do whatsapp internet não é só isso
as formas de conexão à internet de
expressão são gigantescas
eu convido vocês que têm uma intenção de
criar alguma coisa que crêem que postem
que coloquem suas idéias na internet é
muito fácil de fazer isso
usem o seu tempo livre como a gente está
falando em acidente com o coletivo para
espalhar o conhecimento que vocês podem
achar que é uma coisa simples uma coisa
besta mas que talvez essa coisa simples
e besta é a mesma coisa simples basta
que a pessoa do outro lado do mundo
também acha que vocês podem fazer um
movimento de dantesco deixar o seu filho
na frente do computador não é trocar ele
dentro do quarto pode ser libertar ele
no mundo deixar alguém jogando um jogo
online é a mesma coisa do meu deixa o
guri brincar na rua
usem a internet não apenas para se
comunicar com quem vocês conhecem mas
para espalhar idéias
a internet e os jogos são veículos
incríveis ea gente pode fazer muito com
isso
inclusive mudar o comportamento das
pessoas através de jogos eletrônicos
competitivos entre várias pessoas
obrigado
[Aplausos]